noël approche à grands pas et le
magazine protégez-vous a cherché à
savoir comment l'habitude de quels sont
les meilleurs achats c'est un déçu qu'on
devrait également éviter marianne paquet
porte-parole du magazine est un vecteur
pour nous en parler bon jour elle
apprend le nom un peu de ce qu'on
retrouve dans l'ensemble quand on est là
on tourne la première page que ce qu'on
attend magazine cette fois ci mais ya
bien sûr tout nouveau pu tester un
magazine mais je suis beaucoup
aujourd'hui pour vous parler de
répertoire qui vous bonnet blanc ligne
gratuitement qui est un guide d'achat
hyper complet 372 jouets pour les
enfants de 1 à 14 ans 172 jeux de
société pour les enfants pour les ados
pour les adultes
vous pouvez faire vous facile et votre
magazine parce que vous pouvez faire vos
recherches par catégorie d'âge par prix
par type de jeu par catégorie d'aller
retrouver les avis de nos experts des
familles qui ont déjà testé les jeux et
les jouets où trouver les produits est
également d'un mini note
lorsqu on considérait que le produit
était sur emballés ou même lorsqu'il va
dans le bon vous allez toujours trouvé
ça dans notre répertoire très bien
vraiment vous couvrir tous les arts qu
est ce qui ressort à cette année cette
année on s'est penché sur les jouets qui
éveille la créativité des enfants donc
les jeux d'initiation à la musique de
bricolage de construction on en a testé
29 nouveautés ce qui ressort c'est que
ce sont des jeux qui sont très présents
en ce moment en magasin ils ont tous
l'air très attrayant très intéressant
notre constat nous c'est que la qualité
très variable d'un produit à l'autre et
qu'il faut pas se fier aux prix pour
déterminer de la qualité du produit
alors qu'est-ce que vous recommander on
recommande plusieurs jeux et
dans nos recommandations on a obtenu
compte de différents critères comme la
qualité générale du produit également
l'originalité du thème la clarté des
instructions le niveau d'intérêt et de
plaisir c'est important que ce soit
amusant que l'intérêt soit récupérée de
fois en fois si on veut faire un bon
investissement qu'on recommande dans les
jeux musicaux et un ensemble de
percussions cinq instruments de maracas
tambourins que ça fait cher avant de
voir la surface qui n'a pas de sens là
dessus pour faire du volume pour les
airs et jean protégez-vous jamais un jeu
qui a beaucoup plu aux familles qui ont
testé parce que les deux qualités bonne
qualité du matériel et des sont parfaits
pour initier les enfants la musique
également pour des enfants plus avancés
par contre ça vient pas avec un cahier
d'apprentissage ou avec des partitions
donc ça prend des parents qui sont
inventifs qui ont déjà quelques idées de
rythme pour initier les enfants
également pour ceux qui aiment les jeux
de construction je pense que c'est votre
briquet yeux pour les enfants de 3 à 6
ans des pièces 450 pièces le très coloré
on peut faire des animaux on peut faire
des véhicules est ce qui est intéressant
avec ce jeu là c'est que ça vient avec
des paires de yeux
donc on peut personnifié notre
construction mettre un état que ce soit
fatigué ou encore et c'est parfait pour
initier les enfants aux blocs lego ont
rapidement qu'est-ce qu'on évite on
évite un jouet qui s'appelle la guitare
qu'on fait si qui a pas réussi à
atteindre la cible des initiés à la
musique parce que c'est un jouet des
mutations donc l'enfant peut pas
apprendre à jouer de la guitare et peut
même pas accordé l'instrument dont ils
jouent à être un guitariste mais si on
veut initier enfin
musique c'est pas la bonne option juste
société jeux de société compte trois
nouveautés
qu'est ce qui vraiment intéresse les
gens et on ne dénote c'est les jeux
denquête parce qu'on aime les téléséries
enquêtes criminelles interroger des
suspects collecter des des indices dont
chronicles of prime qui a remporté un
grand succès parmi nos nouveautés cette
évaluation l'aca se retrouve en ligne à
partir de données déjà en légions et les
nouveautés ce qu'on a testé cette année
c'est un magazine à partir de demain
merci beaucoup de devoir être la
prochaine